[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster i'm konstantine kitten
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people amazing and returning guests this
week is a rapper and social commentator
zubi welcome back to trigonometry IPP
here guys good to see you both
it's good to see you man anyone doesn't
know you would just remind them that
we've interviewed you before so they can
go and check that out but you're rappers
have the social commentator you've got
quite a big audience now and it's it's a
good time for people with the same voice
like yours to be saying what they think
so
what do you been up to you how's life
what's going on with you yeah things
have been good you know as we record
this we are coming towards the end of
this weird lockdown period we've had
over the past couple of months so I
think this year has been a little bit
weird for everybody in terms of my
career and business things have been
going very well since we last spoke I
mean things things have just started to
go viral when we last spoke but since
then I spent a couple months out in the
US last year I was on a lot of big
podcasts that you're Rogan experience
the Rubin report Ben Shapiro show
obviously this one was a highlight but
my favorites yeah so things things are
being crazy
get getting love all over and my
audience has grown from I think about
50,000 across-the-board on social media
to approaching 400,000 now in just over
a year so it's been it's been crazy
it's been amazing things have been good
and yeah I'm now in a sort of brand new
position that I've never been in in my
life before so I'm sort of navigating
that now independently and it's it's a
new challenge but it's very exciting and
why do you think that you're that you've
managed to grow so phenomenally well I
mean obviously Parvez the fact that
you've gotten that you're on these
podcasts but the reason you're on these
podcasts is because you're quite a
unique voice aren't you in terms of
what's happening now yeah why do you
think that you've grown so far so quick
to put it simply I think that people are
looking for sane an honest voices and
I've always been a saying
honest voice I haven't done something
massively different from what I did
previously apart from showing more of
myself and being went more willing to
participate in some of the conversations
that I used to only have privately and
start putting some of those on Twitter
and other social media talking about
them on my own podcast and other
people's and yeah I think in the past
five years things have gone so sideways
and people are just a lot of people are
feeling silenced a lot of people are
feeling fearful a lot of people are just
feeling like well the world is going
crazy what's going on in society we need
same voices so just like yourselves with
this podcast I think that people are
looking for people who are reasonable
people who are rational willing to have
conversations and not just yell at each
other and yeah I think I fit that and I
also think with my with my background
and my experiences and my personality
I'm just able to bring something
different to the table than sort of your
standard down the line on whatever side
commentator having the perspective
having grown up in Saudi Arabia having
family background originally from
Nigeria going to an American school for
a while living here in the UK just being
able to come at things from different
angles and not being afraid to put my
thoughts out there even if they might be
deemed edgy or controversial or people
disagree with them or whatever one of
the most common things people say to me
multiple times a day is I don't agree
with everything you say but I massively
respect you and I love the fact that you
say it and you're not you know and it's
reasonable it's rational it's not just
trying to rile people up for no reason
we're talking about all of those things
and what's happening right now across
the world the Western world at least the
situation with George Floyd and black
lives matter and all the rest of it I
actually saw you talking about George
Floyd long before most people were
talking about it and you were saying
look this is clearly murder this is
clearly you know police brutality this
guy the police officer needs to be
prosecuted etc and there was some debate
around it at the time people arguing
with you etc but you've gone from being
almost contrarian initially on that
issue to now saying you don't support
black lives matter and you never
and you never would so just take people
like don't you care about black people
[Laughter]
you know it's a given yeah obviously
obviously I care about black people I
every as 99.9% of people do I last time
I checked I was still black I might need
to check with Joe Biden's my family so
the thing here is so firstly talking
about the George Floyd situation
unequivocally you know I saw I saw the
video when it came out I actually saw it
I saw it early before I was talking
about it before I even knew his name was
George Floyd I just saw this video of
this policeman kneeling on this man's
neck and totally he he passes out and
saying he can't breathe in people a
shower I watched the video and it was
one of the most egregious I think that
one and you guys know the Daniel shaver
shooting if you're familiar with that
I'd say those two of all the
unfortunately I've watched quite a lot
of police violence videos from the USA
that have emerged over the years and I'd
say the George Floyd one in the Daniel
Schaffer one with the two that I thought
were most egregious that were just
clearly murder right not like okay I'm
not sure this is a bit debatable
there was a fight or something like that
it was just clear this guy was helpless
you didn't have to do that to it I think
that's one of the things that makes it
so visceral is the this is a helpless
person in handcuffs it is and someone is
should be kneeling on his neck long time
and people are asking him to stop and
George Floyd's and that's what makes it
so deeply deeply disturbing disturbing
yeah it's very and I don't think how
anyone watched that and could see
anything other yeah yeah exactly
and so yeah I felt I just felt morally
compelled to speak on it you know I see
a lot of stuff and I don't I can't speak
on everything otherwise I'd be spending
all day every day just speaking out on
all of these issues but this one was
particularly egregious and I thought it
was important to actually amplify it and
let more people know hey if you guys
seen what has happened here and I did as
you YouTube video on it I just made a 16
minute video which I think over
fifty thousand people have watched now
it's just called George Florida's was
murdered I just shared my view on it and
then so so coming around to what you
were what you're asking about more
recently is um in regards to the black
lives matter thing so there's we I mean
I know why they've called themselves
black lives matter because it's uh the
name is incredibly powerful right cuz no
one disagrees with the statement no one
disagrees with the slogan itself however
black lives matter BLM is an
organization and some people may not
know this there's a difference between
BLM black lives matter the the
organization and the different chapters
that they have and someone just saying
the sentence or the slogan black lives
matter or perhaps putting it on a sign
without necessarily representing the
organization so in hindsight I clearly
could have worded the tweet that I put
out there more carefully I did clarify
it in a second one but I was saying that
the organization itself is not what it
says on the tin right it's not simply
okay we are trying to save black lives
or we are working against injustice is
or you know racial inequities and if
anything like that that that can be a
part of it and that's the that's the
sort of Trojan horse that they're using
for the rest of it but there there's
some very bizarre parts of the ideology
in there the people who founded it the
people who promote it it's run by some
pretty radical black women in America
and there are things in there about you
know wanting to dismantle capitalism
wanting to disrupt the nuclear family
structure wanting to defund and
ultimately abolish the police there
there's all three of those which are
very very very bad ideas and which would
in fact probably disproportionately
affect black American communities and
then there's also not not strictly on
their website but from a lot of the
people in that organization there's also
a lot of race baiting a lot of anti
white rhetoric a lot of you know it's
it's
pretty Marxist stuff in reality and what
they've done is they've sort of taken
that ideology and those views and called
themselves a title that no one can argue
with so if you criticize black lives
matter people are like oh my gosh but
it's called black lives matter you know
it would be like I don't know if I ever
created a terrorist organization I call
it you know peace love and harmony or
something I mean I see straight through
stuff like that mm-hm I think as someone
who does and who looks into these things
in detail I can miss communicate with
people because I almost assume
accidentally that other people kind of
have my eye and my brain to see through
the matrix a little bit and go beyond
what the slogan is and see what's going
on behind here because I think it's I
think it's quite insidious so that was
the reason for that comment most people
got it actually a majority of people who
saw it I believe understood it but a lot
of people definitely did not got you
know some blowback from places including
you know places a little bit close to me
which I wasn't expecting because I
didn't I didn't expect millions of
people to even see the tweet but yeah I
mean in terms of what I was getting at I
know I know why I said it I probably
would have to be honest I wouldn't have
tweeted it I probably would have done
like a whole video on it you know don't
thirty minute video explaining my
position and oh and also in terms of the
BLM as the organization also it's it's
largely a vehicle to fund Democratic
presidential candidates in the US as
well so if you go and you donate to them
it takes you out to a website called act
blue which is a company and website
where if you trace the donations it's
you know the donations often go to you
know Bernie Sanders and Peake Budaj and
all the Democratic candidates etc so in
that sense it's even more dodgy that
they are getting these donations tunes
of hundreds of millions of dollars by
the way I think you know there's not
even a conspiracy theory I think George
Soros himself but a hundred million
dollars into PLM and yeah it's just not
what it's not what people think it is at
least is the organization so people need
to parse
those out but they've intentionally made
it very difficult to do by calling the
name something very noble I mean it's
really interesting you say that because
I went always doing my research on it
and I was reading through with some of
the things that they were saying alarm
bells were going off but because like
you said they marketed it so brilliantly
especially as a white dude going I
actually know I'm on board with it it's
like you know you're taken away but what
you cannot argue is that they have made
this particular issue resonate across
the globe you have demonstrations
Australia Brazil all the rest of it how
have they been able to do that so
brilliantly well well they have got a
lot of funding I've got hundreds of
millions of dollars in funding so
they've got they've got a very big
megaphone and I I think I don't think we
can underestimate the power of slogans
slogans there's something I've kind of
I've always known that slogans are
important but in the past few months I'm
kind of like wow people are really like
no one was talking defund the police two
weeks ago now a defund the police is
like uh it's like a catchphrase defund
the police default item it and it's just
weird how people what would I say the
other day how did I word it something
like human beings are herd animals who
believe we are individual individualist
which is really the case you know I
think that the vast majority of people
all of us to some degree have have some
element of herd mentality but I think
that the people who sort of stand
outside of that and don't kind of just
get swept up in the wave of it which I
think believing includes everybody here
or actually the minority you know that
that's something I've really learned you
know it's a minority position and so
yeah I think the slogans have been
SuperDuper powerful and I think you know
that there is there's no question that
there is an element of good in what
they're promoted of course it's called
black lives matter right accountable I
can't all be bad of course not there are
it's extremely opportunistic because
they they seem to pop up every ever
election year 2016 gets big you know
2020 it gets big and one of my biggest
criticisms of the movement of BLM is the
fact that they focus on 0.001 percent of
black lives so it's funny because
someone if I criticize BLM someone will
try to suggest that either I'm racist or
on caping for racists or something and
one of my biggest criticisms of them is
why do you only care about black lives
when they are killed by a white police
officer in dubious circumstances alright
if the movement is going to be called
black lives matter why why is all the
focus on the 0.001 percent of black
people who are killed in a very certain
specific way at a specific time by a
specific type of person right why can't
we talk about the wider issue right why
aren't we talking about homicide is the
biggest killer of black American males
who are under 40 I believe right and
that that's that's only true for that
demographic right homicide is the
biggest killer so what can we can we
have a conversation about that like can
we can we if it's black lives matter can
we can we talk about that whole thing
can we talk about even nutrition and
diet and people dying of a heart disease
and diabetes
can't why can't we talk about the whole
thing why are we only talking about it
in these very very specific scenarios I
also think that if you wanted to solve
the police brutality issue and you
wanted to stop these unjust police
killings and I differ from a lot of
people on this one I've spoken with
friends family about this and I don't
think everybody understands or agrees
with my position on this but I think you
need to widen the scope right some
people say okay they want to do black
lives matter because they want to focus
on that specific demographic first but
it's like look the majority of people
killed by police in the u.s. are not
black right and people will say yeah but
it's disproportionate to the popular but
I'm like yes but overall only 25 to 30
percent of these police killings or
black victims so this is clearly not
just sure there can be a racial bias
problem here but it's clearly not just
this narrative of the police are riding
around in the USA hunting down lynching
black people like some people are trying
to say you know you can't go outside
your house without fearing for your life
all that really hyperbolic emotional
stuff which I'm no fan of because I
think it distorts it and it prevents
people from finding actual solutions I'm
keen for I would I'm not an American but
I would love for them to find a solution
to this problem I don't think anybody
black white Latino Asian should be
gunned down or choked by a police
officer totally unnecessarily I mean
it's interesting with this George Floyd
case because there was a case a few
years ago with a white man called Tony
tempeh who died in a very very very
similar situation no media outraged no
protests no rioting no looting no nobody
to this day like most people if you say
that name
most people don't don't know who that is
people I was mentioning Daniel shaver
earlier the most egregious police killed
shooting I've ever seen when a white
police officer Y victim totally
unjustified and people don't even know
these cases right I mean and I used to
you know four or five years ago I got
caught up in this loop to write I was
gonna ask you about that because you
have personal experience of this yeah oh
I wasn't even gonna say I wasn't even
talking about that we will get to that
all right yeah but I used to also
believe the narrative that what was
going on in the US with these police
killings was primarily and very
specifically targeting black people
because you used to think that I used to
believe that why because that's all you
see even in the UK well you're an
intelligent educate you on to Oxford you
you look at the data you think about
stuff what which which stories even hit
which stories do you hear about on
social media which story which stories
do the British press talk about have the
British press ever covered a white
American being killed by the police
he's got privileged minds it happens
more than black people killed yeah you
wouldn't know that right and so I saw
because I could name those names all
right I knew about falando Castille
Walter Scott Michael Brown that one's a
different situation era Ghana every
yeah now do you know I could I can name
these names yes there people know the
names and and you know that's what BLM
say you know say their name say their
name and so I sort of got swept into
that whole narrative and I thought okay
this is very very specifically targeting
black people and then when I did look at
the data it was like uh-huh
Oh how come I'm not hearing about the
other 70% mmm that's weird and I looked
into some of the cases I even watched
some of the ones that had videos and I
was like whoa how do people not know
about this I was like okay this is
bigger than the scope here is a bigger
problem than what I thought it was this
is a you know state this is this is a
state violence on citizens issue this is
a police brutality issue this is a
training issue this is a not having high
enough standards issue it's not simply a
racial issue and everyone is trying to
view it purely through that lens and I
think as long as people are trying to do
that I you know I fear that they won't
actually be won't really be resolved
properly because that's not you're
diagnosing the wrong problem and like I
said I think racism can be a part of it
and it likely is in some situations but
for example in the George Floyd killing
people jump straight to the race the
race narrative we don't yet have any
evidence that that was a racially
motivated killing and some people will
even get angry at me for saying that
rocky how of course do be it's obvious
what you mean it's obvious right just
because someone a white person kills a
black person or vice versa that does not
mean it was a racially motivated could
it be sure it could be but we don't have
any we don't have any evidence you know
some people say and then people say well
you know he wouldn't have done that to
like I'm like I've watched a video of
them doing that to a white guy so I
don't know I don't know what's in
Derrick show Ovens heart but the idea
that this never happens to white people
is a lie so it's just wrong it's
factually incorrect it's ignorant and so
I think people need to be willing to
have that whole wider conversation if we
really feel about this on like every
issue people are so bogged down with
trying to maintain certain narratives
and
fit their own confirmation bias and only
look at cases which fit their narrative
and just cherry-pick things and it makes
people feel good and it makes people
feel like they're righteous and they can
shout other people who don't want to do
the same but fundamentally I'm just like
man we can't have such a myopic view on
these issues if we actually do want to
if we do want to resolve and we've got
to be able to talk about the whole
picture and speak about this honestly
and what do you think that this if this
particular incident what do you think
the impact is having on society do you
think it's been since I mean it must
have had some positive impacts on for
instance of what about one of our
friends he talked about what was our big
growing up and being black in South
London sharing experiences that was
really rewarding you go oh I get it
understand a little bit more but there's
also been some negative things as well I
imagine yeah definitely I think yeah
with the problem with society right now
is that I call it emotional incontinence
right like emotions just spray and fly
out everywhere and all these directions
and we're really prone to over
Corrections and overreactions right and
the problem is when it just swings
immediately to hard one way or the other
I mean again and the light of this
killing
there was a rare moment for like 24
hours where everybody 99% of people
republican-democrat black white even
police officers were on the same page
which is actually SuperDuper rare hmm
the George Floyd case was actually very
very peculiar people act like oh this is
just another one in a string and I might
know this one is actually this one's not
contentious hmm this is clear we've got
video it's not going on what people are
saying anyone can watch that video and
I'm like man if you watch that video and
you don't come to the conclusion that
that was not totally unjust you might be
a psychopath right it doesn't matter
your political views and biases even
police officers were like that was out
of order but that's not howell always
completely against that training first
Tom yes exactly
and we all know the police protect our
own and you know and a lot of them
especially in the in the US especially
a lot of sort of more right-leaning
conservatives who tend to be very Pro
police and tend to give them the benefit
of the doubt even they were like no like
no that's clearly a problem so it was
sort of that watershed moment and that's
why I feel quite dismayed how quickly it
went from that agreement to disagreement
and chaos and now people are talking
about riots and looting and talking
about statues now and talking about you
it was like can we keep our eye on the
ball for a moment all right like let's
let's try to resolve let's try to
resolve this one so that cases like that
don't happen again right like let's
let's it's good to be we should be angry
you should be outraged but let's channel
that in the right direction and the
right direction is not burning down your
neighbor's store or you know looting
Target or just causing all this random
random chaos and you know I think with a
lot of these issues what people need to
do is sort of take it take it up a level
I think people get lost in the weeds all
the time and it's like look everybody
agrees that's police brutality is wrong
everybody agrees that racism is wrong
okay so people may differ in what they
think are the causes of police brutality
or how much institutional or systemic
racism exists or what exact the numbers
are and the figures are not but let's
look actually everyone agrees on the
core thing so there need to be there
needs to be some changes made in the
police right there needs to be some
reformation in terms of the training
perhaps you need to look at how much
these people are getting paid I think it
I think it's you know it takes as long
to be a police officer as it does to
become a like a worker in certain shops
or you know it doesn't take a long time
I think you can become a you know might
take longer to become a personal trainer
than to become a police officer and that
should not be the case if you're gonna
get a gun in a badge and you keep in
mind in the u.s. everything is escalated
cuz it's such an armed society so in the
UK the police can afford to be a bit
more chill in the u.s. they they know
every time they go out there they don't
know what they're dealing with every
time they do a traffic stop that's the
most dangerous thing for police
do in America traffic stops all right
that's the position where most of them
get shot and it's like common huge said
when we had him on last week a police
officer gets shot every day every day so
of course they're walking around on edge
worried I'm not necessarily wrongly so
yeah yeah they're on edge and so you
need people of a certain character and a
certain personality type to begin with
and then you need to you need to reward
those people they need to be compensated
well and they need to be trained very
very well moseubi is going to be very
popular with black people where it comes
to the logic and emotion thing right
because some people who are wired a
certain way emotionally will take an
issue with me saying something like that
right but they're not thinking logically
right if you defund the police or you
abolish the police what is gonna happen
and who is it going to hurt the most
it's not going to be the rich
celebrities who have private security
and live in gated communities and are
you know it's easy for them to be anti
border walls and anti guns when they're
surrounded by border walls and guns etc
but for the people who are actually in
communities with high crime and in
places where they can't afford private
security and all that kind of stuff
that's where they need the police you
want the police to be good you want the
lease to be good but the idea that you
just get rid of them and that's somehow
going to the criminals are just gonna
stop because there's no police it's like
what kind of look what kind of logic is
that that's that's crazy and you've seen
this in different places like when the
authority goes when the police goes what
happens you get these the bags of
militias vigilantes and stuff right it's
like look that's not that's really not
the way forward it's very it's very neat
and it seems like right now everything
is everything's just running on emotion
everything's running on emotion and I
can understand that to a degree but as
to someone who is very low on the
emotional scale I'm kind of like look
okay we need some adults in the room and
this needs to be discussed honestly
openly thoroughly and we can get to the
bottom of this I agree with you
justice is not gonna be a problem for me
because I'm gonna go live in chairs not
sure how long you'd like but I the worry
for me is and I think you're absolutely
right about finding a constructive way
forward the worry the worry for me is
how much of this is counterproductive
and I'll tell you why because when you
started talking about George Floyd I
actually didn't comment on initially and
the reason I didn't comment is I had a
friend six or seven years ago who was
one of the people who founded or
co-founded black lives matter okay and
we my wife and I went to visit them
around the time of the Michael Brown
shooting and she was talking about it a
lot at the time so I thought what we're
gonna go and spend two weeks with him I
better do the reading yeah right because
I want to understand what's going on so
I read every word of the Grand Jury in
whatever it's called the process that
document it was the deliberations on the
grand jury investigation and the truth
is that the original claim in that
situation was hands up don't shoot
Michael Brown was on his knees with his
hands in the air pleading for his life
haven't done nothing wrong the reality
is and black witnesses and white
witnesses and ballistic evidence and all
the evidence in that case showed that he
attacked the police officer he was
moving towards the police officer when
he was shot right so complete mismatch
and so in my mind I'm like well I don't
know what's true anymore so I'm gonna be
extra careful before I comment on yeah
and that's my worry but a lot of the
stuff that you talk about being
emotionally incontinent is if you create
a narrative and then people find out
that big gaps in that narrative on
accurate well people are gonna start to
doubt the whole narrative yep is that a
concern do you think yeah definitely I
mean uh in most cases I don't I don't
speak on stuff immediately I've learned
I've learned not to do that the reason I
felt I could and felt compelled to on
this one is because of the video just
saw
Yeah right I watched the whole video it
wasn't edited it wasn't like I just saw
20 second clip maybe I've just you know
the picture of you know the guy's knee
on his neck or something so I know I
watched it and I was like okay there is
nothing there's nothing that can come
out here that makes me go okay that was
justified like this there's there's no
situation I've seen other ones where you
know you don't you don't really see what
happens in those situations I I stay
quiet at least initially because you
know one I don't I don't speak on
everything like this it's too much but
in those ones it's like I don't know
like let's see let's see what happens I
think in the social media age of course
this part of the problem is that there's
this rush for people to quickly cast
judgments and to get the likes and get
the retweets and get the shares by being
the first person to just say something
and denounce it and probably say
something super hyperbolic like you know
this is this is the reality of black men
everyday in America you can't go outside
your house without fearing the police
and being lynched and you see people
making these kind of statements normally
with a blue check and it'll have a
hundred thousand likes and retweets and
it gives them some juice but ultimately
stuff like that doesn't help it really
doesn't help because you know and it
doesn't help the other way either when
you get people who are like so Pro
police that the police could like shoot
someone in the face completely
defenseless and they'll still be like
well you know this is a statistical
anomaly and it's like look that
shouldn't happen there are some things
that should never happen like situation
like George Floyd should never have
unzipped so you can you can reduce those
to zero right there are some cases you
know majority of police shootings are
justified you know I know I don't like
to see anybody die in any way but
majority you don't hear about them over
a thousand last year I think in the US
but you don't hear about them because it
was you know someone was trying to shoot
that more someone was in the in the
middle of committing a felony or
something like that and but um yeah I
just what what I miss I this is this is
what I'm all about I'm about honesty
inauthenticity and I wish people would
just stop lying I wish people would kind
of just this goes for so many things as
people are not being honest and
authentic the narrative has become
more important than the truth but don't
you think we've come to a point in
society where if you stand up and tell
the truth on any particular wide range
of particular issues he's not gonna win
well for you well I think it will in the
long term mmm and I think people are too
myopic with this this is what I was just
funnily enough talking about on my
social media earlier today which is that
in terms of people silencing themselves
and no one you know canceled culture and
no one wanting to voice opinions that
don't tow certain lines and narratives
is it's extremely short-term thinking
it's very very myopic and it's like sure
it might make you feel safe for now but
what about in five years 10 years 15
years 20 years people say ah but you
know I've got kids I'm like yeah well
what kind of world do you want your
children to inhabit what kind of society
and culture do you want them to grow up
and do you want your children not to be
able to express any view or anything in
20 years because we've become so rigid
and we've literally got the thought
police out there and no one can do
anything no it's supposed to be a free
country and if you're in a free country
that's supposed to have freedom of
speech then people need to exercise that
it can't it can't be taken can't be
taken for granted
so yeah sure you might have to deal with
a couple of mobs or I say mobs I'm
talking a real mob I'm not saying that's
people coming with pitchforks and
burning down your house life and I
should dominate coming normally like an
online thing and it's very temporary I'm
sure you you guys have faced this before
and yeah you might get some level of
professional criticism or you know
things even in your own family or most
your friendship we might cause certain
rifts and things like that but
ultimately honesty is truly the best
policy and the long in the long run if
you look at it most people I think who
have been stood by honesty and stood by
authenticity and told the truth whether
that's a you know huge range of
podcasters whether that's you know
myself whether that's the you know the
Jordan Petersons of the world right they
just stood on their principles same with
us but
but there's a privilege there and it's
not white or black it's a self-employed
privilege as well because if you work
for an institution or you you're you're
you stock the shelves in ASDA
there was a guy got fired from his job
in azdak his she shared a comedy routine
from Billy Connelly about religion sure
right you got fired okay I think the
reason a lot of people are scared is
they're scared that they're gonna lose
their source of income because they're
gonna get fired and people are getting
fired left right and center over this
current discussion sure so what do you
say to those people
I'd say it's temporary and I'd say to
the people who are not fired I'd say to
everybody else to society as a whole we
need to stick up for each other people
need to stick up for their friends for
their colleagues etc if you work in a
business and you know one of your
colleagues is under pressure for liking
a tweet or sharing a joke or something
you know something silly I'm not talking
about something super egregious then
people as a whole rather than letting
that person you know prover bleeeh
verbally catch the bullet they need to
surround that person and support them
and say no like talk back to the company
because you know companies are run
companies are just groups of people
right and they're trying to protect our
bottom line but everything is rooted in
cowardice it's all cowardice just
collective cowardice it just takes
people collectively go you'd look up
enough of this it's canceled culture
stuff like to stop like we're not we're
not having this right you can just deep
LAT form people and fire people and keep
you know for having basic because they
voted for Briggs it because they support
this because they don't support that etc
it's like that's not that's not what
this society is supposed to be like and
it's important for people to not be
passive and to actively push back
against that and not just expect people
like myself people like yourself people
certain people to sort of carry that
entire burden and to do the whole thing
for them because you can't you can't
outsource in all elements of courage you
know and sure in the short term the boat
might rock a little bit I don't doubt
that I don't question that right this
guy who works in as the stacking shelves
you know in the short term okay that
kind of sucks you know but
firstly I think he that wouldn't happen
if his colleagues backed him up right if
people on mass backed him up I think
that wouldn't happen to begin with maybe
it was just a dick you know it's like
it's like dominoes yeah right yeah it's
the opposite it's this crescendo and it
it needs to reverse back the other way
and because because the vast majority of
people who feel like this who feel kau
to feel like they can't speak we're not
talking about people who have like
legitimately like extreme we're not
saying about actual knots he's an actual
fascist we're just you know some girl
who I vote it breaks it who actually I
voted Boris Johnson you know or I I
believe this or I believe that you know
I've had people just they're just
Christian you know what I mean it's like
yeah I'm a Christian but like I can't
really I'm like what do you what's going
on like this is not so you know it's
it's bizarre it's very very strange and
it's not just in the UK I when I was in
the US last year I kept having the same
conversation with people because I
didn't meet ups in different cities and
I had people you know whether they were
students at university or you know they
were working at this job or working
there or people in entertainment and
they're just like man like you know this
is that kind of speaking in whispers
almost I'm kind of like guys this is not
it's not sustainable and I'm glad you're
I'm glad you appreciate me being someone
who speaks up and who tells the truth
but I'm just one person I'm one guy and
I'm not I'm not even the best person in
the position to do this I think some
people think I'm just got like you know
multi-millions in my bank account and so
I can kind of do it it's like no that's
not the case I just believe in honesty
and authenticity I don't put all of my
thoughts out there I'm not saying you
have to you have to go like super crazy
but if it's a basic a basic principle
look at what's been happening with JK
Rowling recently right on one hand
there's a bit of schadenfreude
because she's catered so hard to that
audience and sort of help to create this
beast is now trying to eat her but at
the same time it's like yeah big up to
her because she just is dating she's
dating a fashion
actually stating truth and even if issue
was just stating her opinion she isn't
she's entitled to that right and it's
like what kind of world are we living in
where a woman says that people who
menstruate are called women and this is
some huge controversy no it's who's come
in many different shapes and forms what
is that that's crazy and that's gonna
get worse if people don't and one thing
I would say as well on the Jake or
anything I think it's really important
for all of us who are on the side of
honest discussion and whether you agree
with her frankly or not just whether
you're interested in in having a
conversation versus just cancelling
people don't agree you might want to
check biology I know I don't I'm trying
to keep it broad but I guess what I'm
saying is the schadenfreude I can
totally understand we had Graham Linehan
on the show who you know he was involved
in canceling people yeah significantly
and we were very happy to have him on
the show and JK Rowling the same we were
trying to get her on as well because
when people let go of that mentality we
have to welcome them in and we have to
say you've let go of that you're welcome
yeah we welcome you you're not out in in
the desert because of your past behavior
you [ __ ] up in the past you did you
made mistakes but now you get to come
back into civil society and have a
conversation with people and in that's
really important that forgiveness that
we always talk about yeah I know you're
big oh no we're big in it we actually
have to practice it as well yeah
definitely yeah I'm with you 100% on
there and and just it's funny it's like
in some ways it feels like being liberal
has become a conservative position David
yeah yeah and and it's odd I mean there
are people who call themselves liberal
and you know that's how they identify
and I'm like I am more liberal in you in
terms of actually like upholding the
value what are classically liberal
things freedom of speech ability of
people to to dissent to meet and talk to
who they want to not be sort of
ostracized permanently for
their views are their opinions all this
kind of stuff like there's tons of stuff
in the world I do not agree with there's
a lot of stuff I do not agree with but
people have a right to their views they
have a right to their opinions I would
never try to g-platform someone off of
social media or come for that job I try
to cut out their sponsor because they
said something in a podcast I disagree
like that's crazy how can you how can
you support anything along those lines
and consider yourself liberal I mean
that's it's it's bonkers and people are
waking up to this like I said people are
waking up I just think that collectively
and I do try to give people courage and
encourage people in different ways to
just be like hey you know whatever
situation you're in if you're in school
if you're at university if you are you
know in your workplace just online etc
just be willing to do you know if you
even if I don't agree with your all of
your principles or values alright just
you have a right to them and that's okay
too to express them and I'm on your side
I'm on the side of anyone who can agree
to that basic tenets
it's it's really that simple but zubi
you were talking about cowardice and
there's something I want to focus on in
particular because I don't think it's
just the Carrodus of individuals I also
think it's cowardice of the press yes
and you know you see that with the black
lives matter demonstration Dominic
Cummings you know evil get rid of him
destroy him that's literally burning his
house but then everyone goes out on a
mass demonstration during a pandemic and
suddenly that's okay and I'm like is it
and my racists were thinking it might
not be no and a week it's not like it
happened ten years ago
it's literally last week yeah yeah I
mean just yesterday I don't know I came
from what was NBC it was one of the US
newspapers Twitter and an hour before
they were talking in happy terms about
thousands of people gathering for black
trans lives matter rally and
demonstration thousands of people you
know can see the pictures and then an
hour later the same account tweeted
condemning the fact
that Trump was going to restart his
rallies and that health experts sort
saying that this is a terrible idea
within an hour the same account and
you're just like come on dude come on
you know and it's just like you're
you're totally right when I see what I'm
talking about cowardice and I'm talking
about honesty and I'm talking about
authenticity I'm speaking across the
board I'm talking to individuals I'm
talking to the media I'm talking to
corporations I'm talking to world
leaders if everyone just told the truth
or at least tried to so stuff would just
be so much better right just just do
that and allow other people to do the
same be willing to have conversations
and just actually be liberal in the in
the in the proper sense of that word and
it'll also you know one thing that part
of the reason why I feel compelled to to
do what I do and to talk to people on
all sides etc I get quite a lot of
sometimes not that often some some
people give me a little bit of flak
because you know I will talk to people
across the board and some people like oh
you shouldn't be talking to those mag
apeople or you shouldn't be talking that
I'm like look guys firstly don't tell me
who I should talk to because you don't
own me and I'm my own man and I'm not
telling you who to talk to so like you
know courtesy and then secondly it's
like you want to understand people right
you want to whether whether I disagree
agree disagree right if I meet a raging
communist I want to talk to you too cuz
I'm like what why you said you know
what's going on here right we need to we
need to talk to each other and
understand each other even if you still
disagree and then ultimately and then
also this is the one that I don't think
people talk about a lot is it's
important to keep people remotely
moderated and to stop people from people
are already fracturing you hear a lot of
people talk about political polarization
and division and if you don't want that
to get like really bad you you need to
hold the middle the middle needs to be
held whether someone considers themself
like a you know a conservative or
liberal or centrist or moderate
libertarian all these people we need to
hold the middle right we may have
differing views between us but we're all
we're all sort of in the same tent
so that needs to be held because
otherwise people run off in more extreme
directions right if you refuse to talk
to anybody here or you've refused to
talk to anybody there then the only
people they'll talk to or you know the
people who might be a little bit more
radical than them more radical than them
and that's how people end up sort of
drifting off and as you guys were saying
if you don't offer people a way back in
right then you think about all the
people think about the people who have
been been kicked off of social media
right permanently people just kicked off
of social media
cut their PayPal cut their funding don't
let them do this don't let don't let
them have a bank account do you think
that's gonna moderate them like that's
when you're gonna that person is now
likely that's the person you need to
keep an eye on because who are the
people who are gonna be like oh come
talk to us you know we'll talk to you or
it's gonna be the other people who
already are you know not not beyond the
pale but more radical and more extreme
in certain ways and that's literally how
people get that's how people get that's
how people get radicalized and also it's
just um it's also just not kind it's not
fair if you want to we talk a lot about
kindness and fairness and tolerance and
diversity but rather than just paying
lip service to these things think about
what they really mean and actually try
to act on them and it's not kind to cut
someone's funding and get them fired
from their job and make sure that they
can never live and eat again or feed
their children because they said
something you don't like or maybe they
genuinely maybe they genuinely cocked up
right maybe they genuinely did something
bad right but should now they have to
suffer and they can't they can't do
anything now sigh come on that's not
what kind of society does that to people
how much of it is about the fact that
certain groups have changed the meaning
of words ooh mmm because if you convince
people that if I if you say look up
biology if you don't agree with JK
Rowling that is quote-unquote error
raising the existence of trans people or
if you criticize the black lives matter
organization you are erasing or
committing violence against black people
or you know we can go down the whole
list you know if you don't agree that
the gender pay gap is what people say
then you're hurting women like what like
you can go down right so we have become
convinced now that silence is why like
silence is violence Speaking is violence
but violence isn't the right person if
it's by the reference so how much of
this is about the fact that very
sneakily
these people have substituted meanings
for words they know don't apply at all
yeah sure but I don't like to use the
terms the left and the right but the
left broadly speaking is very very good
at this very very good at changing the
language and controlling the net the
language and controlling the parameters
in which people speak it's incredibly
clever and it's been happening for many
many many decades and people need to
wake up to that and not play the game
there are a lot of words in terms I
dunno I refuse to use I just don't use
them because I'm never gonna call
someone a sis man or a sis woman I'm
never gonna use the term violence in
relation to something that's not actual
violence I'm never going to what are
some other terms that that are used
right I refuse to you know bastardizing
the English language to fit people's
ideology because I I know why it's done
and it's just done it's a weapon it's a
tool right it's a tool right because if
you can control people's 9th 1984 if you
can control people's words and language
you can ultimately control their thought
and you can move the Overton Window so
that someone now saying something benign
like there are only two genders can now
be deemed as violence or hate speech or
an attack or an erasure of people's
existence right and they always go from
0 to 100 real quick right if you just
might your mod ly critical or something
and suddenly you want to erase someone
zig-zig existence and you don't think
they should be allowed to it's like whoa
oh hang on hang on hang on who didn't
say any of that
and so people need to not play the game
right just not play that game if there's
words or terminology and things you
don't agree with or someone is trying to
redefine the meaning of a word right
someone says racist and they're trying
to convince you that it means you know
that black people can't be racist only
white people can be racist because
racism is now privileged plus power yeah
that's it's discrimination plus power
and if you don't have the Institute
right that don't play that game I don't
just say no that's BS know what it is
but don't you also think that there's a
lot of people who do very very well out
of propagating their appearances it's an
industry there's a Billy big worth
billions worth billions and you should
get in a no man's the grievance industry
whether that's you know corporate
feminism or its corporate race-baiting
or you know and and politicians all
right that's how they get votes because
again like I said most people have this
herd mentality so it's easy to do people
you know if you if you're a politician
and you speak in a certain way and you
play the identity politics game then
they do it because it it works and I
don't know how I can get this message
out there but I'm like it shouldn't
people shouldn't let it work on them
right if a politician gets up tomorrow
and they just start talking all this
stuff about people of color and you know
black people and white supremacy and
dismantling the patriarchy or what I
hate that doesn't work on me I'm like
what are you talking about like you're
just speaking nonsense right you're just
trying to pander to certain demographics
in certain people and actually that's
what I find offensive I find it
offensive you think I'd fall for that
but unfortunately a lot of people do it
does work on them and you get people
saying like oh well they said they'll
they they said they'll do this they sort
of they mentioned my demographic and the
things so that means that they're
they're supporter and I'm like look none
of us should play this game and again if
that game can be played one way it can
be played anyway this is the thing right
I'm very much an equalist so what
concerns me as well with some of the
identity politics being played on one
side is like okay
might think that's all good now but what
is now the argument against the white
nationalists right right I've spoken to
black people and I'm there they'll be
saying some of their opinions on some of
this stuff and I'm like dude you're
literally saying the exact same thing
that white nationalists do you're you're
literally saying the same thing right
when people especially my people start
talking about like separate separatism
right or people talk about only
supporting black businesses or doing
this or you know you know definitely not
you know marrying outside of your race
etc I'm like this is literally the same
thing why nationalists say so unless I
mean if you think that right okay fair
enough y'all can have your you know
white Conda and Wakanda or whatever but
you know for the rest of us who are
quite happy to live in a multiracial
multi-ethnic harmonious society and
don't really care about all that stuff
we don't want to be caught in in that
crossfire and I think that's the thing
you know every action has an equal and
opposite reaction so if people are going
to get like SuperDuper on the let's say
say the black identity train and
bandwagon you then don't have you can't
really say anything if a fringe group of
say white people went off and you know
wanted to form their own white identity
white power movement because you know
you without being a hypocrite
you then can't criticize well they're
saying black power they're saying only
buy from black businesses they're saying
you know don't intermarry etc you know
that's that's what they're saying and
you can't be like oh well that one's bad
and that one's okay because it all falls
apart so again I think people need to
think people need to think more deeply
about this stuff brother I agree with
you but that's why I'm not optimistic
about what's happening right now because
I just alright that's what I see coming
yeah do you think that's kind of I don't
I don't know I'm generally an optimist
by nature generally an optimist by
nature and as I said I think you know
ninety percent of the people in the
middle of this you know are decent this
is also why I don't like this narrative
of people trying to say that you know
that that's a piece
you know I don't like it when people say
things like the UK is a racist country
hmm you know I don't again I don't and
then people get mad at me for not liking
that but it's I don't I don't like that
because you are painting a lot of people
who I know are good decent people who
are not racist who are you're just
saying if you say the UK as a whole or
like British society as a whole is that
it's like well you're kind of talking
about all of us right so if that's not
the case then please word your stuff you
know I'm not trying to language police
people but you know word yourself a bit
more or more carefully right if you say
that there's a difference between saying
there is racism in Britain right and
saying Britain is a racist country those
those are different statements the first
ones I can of course right there amazes
people everywhere but suggesting that
Britain as a whole is racist
it's been 2020 is it's damning a lot of
people and it's just not but even even
in 22 18 20 not everybody was racist
right there were people fighting for the
rights of slaves right so so that's the
thing is like you can't just make these
generalized statements about everything
anything no you know and that's why it's
important that you're you're getting
that message of people need to be honest
and accurate which is what you're really
saying yeah you know yeah it's really
important but listen man it's great to
have you back and you keep putting your
voice out there
you inspire lots of people and then they
inspire others and so on and that's what
we try and do as well so thanks for
coming back on most welcome we've got
one more question for you and it's the
one we always finish with which is what
is the one thing that we're not talking
about but we really should be Wow give
me a second yeah last time you kept a
light and said abortion I think we
should talk more about family family and
the importance of family and family
structures I think one of the biggest
problems facing the West I think the
biggest problem actually is rooted in
family I think the biggest problem is
lack of lack of fathers whether they're
absent or just you know bad parenting I
think a lot of what we're seeing now is
the results
of decades of letting that family
structure disintegrate in many ways and
not have any standards around that so I
think there needs to be more honest talk
and discussion about you know men and
women in society and relationships and
marriage and family and children and and
raising that raising that next
generation I think that again I think
political correctness often gets in the
way of this and we're living in this
time when there aren't supposed to be
it's kind of like they aren't even
supposed to be any standards it's just
kind of like well every family structure
is the same and just do do whatever and
we know that that's not the case if
someone likes data you can even you can
look at the data on that you can you can
see the reality of it there's nothing
worse than not having a father for it
it's it's a big big big problem and a
lot of the stuff we talk about I think
is is rooted in that so i'd like to i'd
love to see society speaking about that
more honestly and openly and again if
you want to talk about you know the
slogan black lives matter and you're
talking about some of the problems in
some of those communities specifically
especially in america so much of it is
rooted in fatherlessness and people
being misguided along those lines so
ultimately if we want to fix that
problem then i think we need to talk
about that that's really important
message man thank you for coming back if
people want to follow you they go to add
zubi music on twitter and just tell
everybody you know they've got a podcast
as well yep sure my podcast real talk
with zubi is available on all platforms
YouTube Spotify Apple podcasts you can
also find my music on all digital
platforms just search for zubi and you
can find me on all social media Twitter
Instagram Facebook YouTube at zubi music
all right thanks guys thanks for
watching make sure you go and follow
zubi and we'll see you very soon with
another Cortland episode take care and
see you soon guys thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word